you see that video of Shapiro doing a
debate and this guy comes up and asks a
question and says why is it that you say
on your Wikipedia that you're five foot
ten when you're five foot four Shapiro
immediately goes how tall are you and he
goes five foot ten he goes okay come up
here it's up and stands up and bends
taller than him that was so funny you
need to you need to check it out it's so
good I mean that's a bold move by
Shapiro because he didn't know what that
guy was gonna say in response so I've
looked at his communication stuff I
think that because he is a public
debater he has been trained to go for
the dunk he didn't address the question
he didn't handle it logically he dunked
and in discrediting the person who asked
the question won the social approval of
the crowd not necessarily Sound Logic
which he may have as well at his
disposal shortcut dunk tactics to
discredit the other side make them look
foolish Etc